Republicans have started the dog and
pony show hearings and the first one
where they wanted to dress down and
Grill Twitter Executives about
anti-conservative bias has backfired so
spectacularly Republicans utterly
humiliating themselves that hopefully
they are talking behind closed doors and
saying we gotta stop doing this stuff to
ourselves because this did not go well
the whole point here was to bring
Twitter Executives in front of a house
panel and to grill them and expose how
they were blocking Trump and banning
conservatives and all of these different
things they did nothing of the sort and
in fact only confirmed how clueless and
ignorant they are about everything from
the way technology Works to what the
first amendment is and isn't but we will
get to that let's look at some clips
here is a Lauren Boberg
Furious principled defiant saying who
the hell do you think you are when you
silenced me or something take a listen
to this did you Shadow ban my account
yes or no did you Shadow ban my account
again not to the best of my recollection
so the answer is Mr Roth yes you did I
found out last night from Twitter staff
that you suppressed my account for this
tweet it's a freaking joke about Hillary
Clinton not being angry that she she
seems completely unhinged couldn't rig
her election it's
[Music]
a nine and I'm realizing part of the
problem with why these things go wrong
is their lack of ability to read out
loud with proper tone and detonation
Lauren bobert understand is reading this
rant that's supposed to make Twitter
look really bad but because her reading
skills transl you know you one of the
things that sometimes can be useful when
when you're doing this type of thing
is you develop a skill where anybody can
really do it you're reading one or two
phrases ahead of what you're saying so
that you can properly contextualize and
have the right tone for what you're
saying now so it doesn't end up sounding
weird when you get to the next thing she
just seems unable to do it so she sounds
very silly
the account filter so I
included me from top searches prevented
notifications for non-followers and much
more this is considered an aggressive
visibility filter you silenced members
of Congress from communicating with
their constituents you can you silenced
me from communicating with the American
people over a freaking joke now who the
hell do you think that you are who the
hell do you think you are
this was really the theme
acting as if criminal things took place
and pretending that it only applied to
right Wingers which we now know of
course that it did not then they brought
in clay Higgins who just seems very dim
and Confused like it genuinely doesn't
seem like he even understands Twitter
and he seemed to be threatening these
ex-twitter employees
with a rest for what crimes I have no
idea let's see if we can figure it out
you ladies and gentlemen interfered with
the United States of America 2020
presidential election knowingly and
willingly that's the bad news it's going
to get worse right because this is the
investigation part later comes the
arrest part
the Europe for what for what crimes
who's getting arrested what are you even
talking about eternities are familiar
with that
Mr chairman I like just spend five hours
with these ladies and gentlemen doing
depositions surely yet to come but for
right now I yield the balance of my time
to my yeah
um earlier during the event and and
again this is all
of course this is all stage managed for
an electorate meaning people who vote
for these Republicans who don't know any
damn better and I understand that but to
anybody with an ability to evaluate what
actually took place here this is a
complete and total joke here's the very
same clay Higgins submitting random
items he found on the internet for
inclusion in the Congressional Record
also submit for the record a timeline of
uh events with cited sources outline and
strong evidence of the Boden family
organized criminal actions
indicate that we've crossed the
threshold of reasonable suspicion we've
crossed the Rubicon based on this thing
I found on Gateway pundit I like this
timeline submitted for the record excuse
me Mr chairman all right just where is
that from that timeline
timeline in my hand boss up I'll get it
to you shortly what did he say what
where is it from I mean I've got to hear
that again from that timeline
timeline in my hand boss up boss up what
is he talking about I'll get it to you
shortly
um
okay so let's include random items from
the internet then it went to uh
representative sessions who took this as
an opportunity to bless Elon Musk that
was you knew that was coming thank you
very much uh so I will say it God bless
Elon Musk yeah
because I I think I feel that way it was
Elon Musk that revealed
data that uncovered a disturbing cabal
right there was a cabal it was uncovered
a cabal in which both the Trump
Administration and the Biden campaign
had the email addresses of people at
Twitter and they could email them and
say hey we'd like this removed now we
are going to get to what Trump wanted
removed from Twitter and again this is
part of the total backfire of this but
let me not get ahead of myself we then
go to Congressman James Comer
Congressman James Comer has been a major
promulgator of conspiracy theories about
the balloon as we have spoken about here
he tries to convince a lawyer to waive
attorney-client privilege for no reason
other than he wants to as I think we've
notified the committee and we've had
these conversations with Twitter as well
to try to resolve this issue prior to
coming up here today I don't have
anything in writing that clears me in my
ethical responsibilities to my former
client right with respect to answering
questions that I think fall squarely
within the attorney client privilege so
unfortunately I don't think I can go
beyond what I've said there already sir
yeah unfortunately Mr Becker you're
assertion that the attorney-clap
privilege uh it it's overruled as to
this particular question and answer so
uh will you
please answer the question we're
overruling attorney-client privilege
just right here just I'm just doing it
with my gavel Jordan
point of order Mr chairman
State support uh well I as I understand
it because we just went through this in
the January 6 committee where multiple
Witnesses asserted attorney-client
privilege including people who weren't
covered by it at all and ultimately
that's that's the funny thing remember
the degree to which attorney-client
privilege was cited by Trump
Administration people when there were
like no lawyers even in the room and now
all of a sudden an actual lawyer in a
completely legitimate use of
attorney-client privilege no no no just
talk about it anyway tell us anything
work to decide so I don't think there's
I don't think there's anything we can do
within the committee at this point
unless I'm missing something no uh Jamie
Raskin is missing nothing uh whatsoever
this was humiliating a really
interesting moment uh congresswoman
Alexandria ocasio-cortez she took some
of the time she had to detail how this
account lives of tick-tock actually
incited harassment against Real World
Health Care workers at Boston Children's
Hospital but was still allowed to remain
on Twitter again sort of disproofed by
counter example A compelling moment take
a look at this Miss navaroli are you
familiar with the account Libs of tick
tock
I have heard of it from the news yes
um Mr Roth are you familiar with this
account
yes ma'am I am
are you aware from that from August 11th
to August 16th that account posted false
information about Boston Children's
Hospital claiming that they were
providing hysterectomies
to children
yes I am aware of that and other claims
from the account and are you aware that
this lie was then circulated by other
prominent far-right influencers
yes
and are you aware that all these claims
uh which I have reiterated were false
culminated in a real-life harassment and
ultimately a bomb threat
to the Boston Children's Hospital
yes I am aware and this account is still
on that platform today isn't it
regrettably yes it is despite inspiring
a bomb threat due to the right-wing
incitement of violence against trans
Americans in this country because they
cannot
let go of this obsession
with fixating violence and inciting
violence against trans and LGBT people
in addition to immigrants in addition to
women of color this is a party that
cannot pick on anyone their own size
yeah so this really just a terrible idea
for republicans and the idea that this
was a concerted effort to silence the
ride has been so widely debunked the
flopped Twitter files themselves
debunking that notion we have video here
of Congressman Pat Fallon citing a
completely dubious poll saying if the
hunter Biden stuff had been left on
Twitter Trump would have actually won so
there in the media Research Center
pulled Democratic voters in 2020 swing
States and found that 17 would have
changed their vote if they'd known the
contents and evidence of the New York
Post story
president Trump lost
key States Georgia Pennsylvania
Arizona and Wisconsin by collectively
just over a hundred thousand votes and
if this is accurate this poll 3.2
million votes could have swung
and he only needed a teeny fraction of
those 3.2 million yeah it's Twitter's
fault because they censored Hunter
Biden's genitalia that Trump did not
ultimately win now remember it is
against Twitter's terms of service and
it is a crime in almost all 50 states to
publish explicit images of an individual
without that individual's consent and
that is why that content was removed so
we eventually got to a summary from
democratic Congressman Maxwell Frost
which is really good I I I'm a fan of
this guy so far from what I have seen
and his summary is completely correct
sitting here for over two hours and I'm
still not really seeing the point of
this hearing me neither is it to solve
the problems of the American people what
people are struggling with no no we we
get it my Republican colleagues wish
that the hunter Biden story would have
helped them win the 2020 election and
that didn't happen and so they're angry
about it and that's the point of this
hearing yeah you know it was actually
the the foundation of the Chairman's
opening statement it's why he brought up
that that poll on the 2020 election
that's what this is all about yes it is
about that and about continuing to turn
Americans against big Tech platforms not
for reasons that should make us
concerned about the platforms but for
Imaginary reasons uh like this decidedly
uh anti-conservative bias that they
claim exists this is what you can expect
for the next two years Republicans who
are essentially the school bully
while complaining they are the victims
of bullying that's fundamentally what
you have here and we are going to have
pointless hearing after senseless
investigation for the next two years
hopefully those hearings will blow up in
their faces as much as this one did
where they make a claim and they swear
it's true and then it's proven that
they're wrong but we're still going to
have a hearing because we still say it's
true and of course it's not it doesn't
matter
to many of their supporters that these
hearings blow up in their faces because
their supporters don't live in reality
and they don't care now there's a couple
things from this hearing that I did not
include in this summary because I think
they're worthy of their own discussion
and let's get to one of those things
right now Marjorie Taylor green during
yesterday's failed humiliating instantly
imploding Twitter hearings wrongly
claimed that Twitter broke the law when
they suspended her account because she
violated their terms of service she
doesn't understand the law or the First
Amendment but her followers don't either
so this stuff is really effective listen
to her rant let's explain
52 United States law
10101 no person shall intimidate
threaten coerce or attempt to stop any
other I've never heard the word coerce
pronoun coerce she really speaks in an
interesting way per person for the
purpose of interfering with their rights
to vote or to vote as he may choose you
didn't Shadow ban or permanently ban my
Democrat opponent because your Democrat
opponent didn't violate Twitter's terms
of service
no you did that to me
and that was wrong and it was against
the law it was against the law wait no
it wasn't
you see not only that was it was it me
that you violated my first amendment
rights you violated countless
conservative Americans these were
doctors that were trying to tell the
truth about coven doctor they were
liners that were having success treating
people with Ivermectin that is not a
scientifically demonstrated claim and in
fact Ivermectin does not work on covid
that you all would not allow to be
talked about on your platform these were
parents complaining about their school
boards teaching gender lives in their
schools biological males entering their
daughter's bathrooms and sports
these were also people questioning the
2020 election and guess what that's
Americans First Amendment right notice
how on that one she doesn't say they
were right to question it she's now
moved to they are allowed to question it
under the First Amendment Now understand
that Marjorie Taylor green has no clue
and no understanding of the First
Amendment nor of the law so I know many
of you know this but let's put it
together nice and concisely here as far
as the first amendment goes it applies
to the government it does not apply to
private companies like Twitter so when
Twitter decides to ban someone it is not
a violation of their constitutional
rights could Twitter commit a crime by
Banning people sure if Twitter was
Banning people
either overtly or it could be
demonstrating demonstrated that they
were targeting people of certain
protected classes for Banning if Twitter
all of a sudden was Banning Jews from
Twitter for being Jewish or Banning
black people from Twitter because they
were black that would be a crime it
wouldn't be a First Amendment issue it
would be a non-discrimination issue but
the First Amendment does not apply to
Twitter now then you get to the second
part of the argument which is that some
people argue that because Twitter is
such a big platform it should be treated
as a public forum now that is not the
law that is not the law it is not the
law but let's imagine for the sake of
argument that we accept that that's the
way it should be
the First Amendment also doesn't
guarantee the right to speech in all
circumstances nor does it guarantee
freedom from consequences of your speech
there are still limits on speech
incitement to violence or whatever the
case may be it is circumstantial but
that's if we imagine that the law is
different than it is and Marjorie Taylor
green said this was a First Amendment
violation and it was a crime
even if someone's speech isn't ex
prohibited social media platforms still
have the right to set their own
standards and enforce them as they see
fit I've been the Target or I guess I
could say the victim of the
misenforcement of these policies when
YouTube was it YouTube No when Instagram
had a policy against coveted
disinformation I did a video
covering a guy who said drink urine for
covet okay I didn't say drink urine for
covet I would never do that I wouldn't
suggest distilling urine drinking it
injecting it using it uh for flambe I
would not suggest urine for covet in any
way
however I was caught up
and we had a problem because the terms
of service were misapplied because I
quoted someone spreading covert
disinformation I was caught up in it it
wasn't a crime I disagreed with that
because it was not an application fairly
of the terms of service but none of it
relates to criminality
but with them everything's always a
crime now one other argument that
Republicans sometimes make is that
social media censorship is biased
against conservatives the reality is
social media companies are private
businesses they can enforce their
policies however they want if they
wanted to ban conservatives they would
be allowed to do that now again it goes
back to well Twitter so big it should be
regulated in a different way should be
and is are two completely different
things and lastly remember that these
social media platforms aren't the only
way to communicate with others to
express themselves so one of the
arguments people like Marjorie Taylor
green are making are have been
when I am running a campaign against
someone else I'm speaking as a Marjorie
now I know it's hard to imagine but I'm
speaking as Marjorie she argues when I'm
running a campaign against someone else
and you ban me and not them essentially
it's almost like a campaign contribution
of sorts it's against the law you're
silencing me first amendment oh we've
debunked basically every aspect of that
but the other thing you have to remember
is Twitter is not the only way that you
run a campaign Twitter is not a
requirement to run campaigns there's TV
she can put her videos up on on YouTube
Facebook all these different things she
can be interviewed Etc
so also in that way it is neither a
crime nor a violation of anyone's rights
absolute last thing on this there's also
the business regulation hypocrisy of
these people when they make these claims
on the one hand Republicans claim to be
against government intervention and
business and at the same time here they
are demanding Twitter should be forced
to publish someone's tweets why that's
extremely heavy-handed regulation to
come in and say to a private business we
as the government are going to tell you
you've got to publish urine conspiracies
you've got to publish marjorie's
conspiracies or whatever the case may be
so this is absurd in every way Marjorie
Taylor green is wrong on every one of
these claims but you go to a trump rally
and you interview people and they go oh
Twitter's violating People's First
Amendment rights because they don't know
any better all of these clips will be on
our YouTube channel youtube.com slash
the David Pacman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
so there's just one more aspect of
yesterday's completely clown car
humiliating Twitter hearings that
Republicans orchestrated now that they
control the House of Representatives
that I want to look at separately and it
is about the snowflake triggered nature
of the failed former president Donald
Trump who tried to get a tweet from
celebrity Chrissy Teigen about him
removed from Twitter now there is some
strong language in this segment I'm
giving you fair warning even before I
get to it I'm just letting you know that
there is strong language in this segment
um one of the stories that has been told
by the right is that the Biden
Administration which of course was not
an administration at the time it was it
was a campaign
was demanding content be removed from
Twitter
simply because it was disadvantageous to
Joe Biden now when you evaluate that
claim what you find out is that the
Biden Administration wanted explicit
images of Hunter Biden shared without
his consent against Twitter terms of
service and a crime in Most states
removed and that was absolutely
legitimate but we have now found out
that there was a TR a tweet which just
was insulting to Trump that he wanted
removed here is a congressman Frost
speaking to Twitter Executives about
this again there is strong language here
listen to what it was that Trump wanted
removed from Twitter
yeah Miss uh uh niravoli earlier you
testified about a 2019 tweet
um that was about President Trump and I
think it's from uh Miss Teigen what was
the Tweet about
would you like me to give the direct
quote yeah
um please excuse my language this is a
direct quote but Chrissy Teigen referred
to Donald Trump as a ass
okay
free speech and what happened after Miss
Teagan posted her tweet what did the
White House do what did the Trump White
House do from my understanding the White
House reached out to ask that this tweet
be removed now folks that's not a
campaign that's an Administration that
is government
calling Twitter emailing Twitter sending
a smoke signal to Twitter and saying
remove the speech of this private
citizen on a private platform it was my
team's job this fell underneath the
policy for abusive behaviors and we
evaluate it underneath our insults
policy at that time up to three insults
were allowed and so it was our job to
determine how many insults were included
within that phrase right right White
House reached out not an agency but the
White House reached out and request that
you remove the the tweet from my
understanding yes yeah
that is the epitome of these right
Wingers the left wants everything
censored well they want images that are
a crime censored but you want Chrissy
Teigen censored because she called you
names and the irony is that Trump's
attempt to censor the Tweet
reinforces the accuracy of Chrissy
teigen's tweet that's the the amazing
thing they say Twitter censoring
conservatives while they are demanding
that liberals be censored for opinions
that are of no National Security
implication they're not doxing anybody
nobody's at risk nobody's in danger
Trump has the best protection ever even
if someone saw Chrissy teigen's tweet
and they wanted to go and do something
to trump it is the uh uh theme of
authoritarian narcissists being very
thin-skinned people like Trump and we
can look in history and find other
examples they see
statements they see criticism like this
as a threat to their power and their ego
Hitler Stalin Kim Jong-un just to name a
few they all had the same uh personality
trait Hitler as the leader of Germany
was Infamous for his sensitivity to
criticism and he saw media as a tool for
propaganda he would suppress criticism
of his regime he would censor newspapers
he would jail journalists because these
authoritarian narcissists
see themselves as threatened by any kind
of criticism another example Joseph
Stalin former leader of the Soviet Union
Stalin would brutally repress dissent he
would imprison and sometimes execute
critics and political opponents he saw
criticism as a direct threat to his Rule
and he did everything he could to
silence it and then more recently in
North Korea Kim Jong-un um and and
there's more it goes earlier than just
Kim Jong-un Kim Jong-il and others but
an authoritarian leader who is so
thin-skinned Kim Jong-un notorious for
strictly controlling information
suppressing dissent and Doling out
severe punishment for criticism of the
regime Trump is not Hitler Stalin or Kim
Jong-un
but Trump has that same authoritarian
narcissistic tendency that they do and
it's embarrassing and it's pathetic and
again
allegations are confessions the left is
trying to censor our speech they're not
but you're trying to censor the left
speech that's what we keep learning you
know I've gotten a lot of emails over
the last month or so from people saying
David sir I hear it vaguely mentioned
that the Republican party is now more
extreme than ever but is that true is it
true that the Republican party has
actually moved to the right and
particularly in the context of looking
at people like Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bobert and similar extremist
lunatics in the Republican party it's
reasonable to ask has it always been
like this and the truth is that it has
not this is not a segment about how
great the Republican party used to be
this is a segment about how much less
extreme the Republican party used to be
for those who don't know the history the
Republic looking party was once a
relatively moderate political force in
the United States compared to where they
are today over the last 40 years there
has been a radical transformation in the
Republican party where it has become
more and more extreme in its views and
its policies in its rhetoric and in the
level of extremism that it is willing to
accept within its ranks again I might
have to say this 20 times I'm not
rehabilitating the old Republican Party
I'm comparing what it used to be to what
it is today and one of the most glaring
sort of examples of this shift has been
the party's view on social issues in the
70s and 80s there were many elements of
the Republican party that were generally
and and sort of superficially at least
supportive of abortion rights and of gay
rights but we know that that has changed
dramatically and it is a party that has
won many elections and raised a ton of
money being completely against abortion
and completely against LGBT rights if
you go to the 70s and 80s you can find
that abortion rights and LGBT rights
were simply not as partisan as uh we're
not partisan issues to the degree that
they are today and you had some
Republicans that were actually
supportive of those causes if you look
at president Richard Nixon one of the
first politicians to publicly support
abortion rights in a 69 speech he said
this should be a decision made by a
woman and her doctor not the government
that's the small government position on
abortion in 72 the Republican Party
platform included a plank supporting
abortion rights to some degree they
maintained that for four years and in
1976 the Republican Party became
significantly more anti-abortion uh you
go to 1977.
a republican-led Congress passed a bill
known as the gay rights Bill and it
banned discrimination on the basis of
sexual orientation in the federal
government and in Washington D.C that
was a republican-led congress at the
time you then look at
um Ronald Reagan in 86 when Reagan
signed the immigration reform and
Control Act it actually provided some
legal protections for Gay and Lesbian
immigrants to the United States in 87
the Republican Party platform included
language supporting anti-discrimination
measures for Gay and Lesbian Americans
so it's not that those views necessarily
reflected the views of the entire
Republican party at those points in time
but there used to be support at least to
some degree for those causes among
Republicans in the 70s and 80s that's
social issues taxation
in the past Republicans were open to the
idea that we might raise taxes if it
meant funding important programs or if
it would reduce the deficit today they
never even acknowledge that uh uh
increasing taxes to fund certain
programs can actually reduce the deficit
by being economically stimulative they
pretend that that's not an economic
reality anymore and we know the result
it's led to the erosion of so many
different social programs immigration is
an area where the views of the
Republicans have changed quite
dramatically in the past Republicans
were often supportive of immigration
side as a source of economic growth sort
of we're okay with the cultural
diversity component of it as well but
now we've seen the Republican Party
become obsessed with building a border
wall cracking down on immigration saying
we shouldn't even provide a path to
citizenship to people who were brought
here as kids by their parents through no
fault of their own but when you go back
to 86 I mentioned that Immigration
Reform Act that President Reagan signed
it provided amnesty to millions of
undocumented immigrants already living
in the United States and Reagan said at
the time quote the legalization
Provisions in this act will go far to
improve the lives of a class of
individuals who now must hide in the
shadows without access to many of the
benefits of a free and open society that
was Reagan who said that John McCain in
2005 co-sponsored the comprehensive
Immigration Reform Act which would have
provided a path to citizenship for
undocumented immigrants Mitt Romney as
recently as 2012 expressed support for
comprehensive immigration reform which
would have given a path to citizenship
for some undocumented immigrants so this
has been a change at climate change I'll
mention briefly
you had a time in the past
when Republicans were open to talking
about what actions should we take to
address the issue of climate change they
didn't necessarily agree with Democrats
on what those actions actions should be
but they agreed on the science they
didn't question the science you now have
much of the Republican party that just
says oh no the science is completely
wrong so the Republican parties shift to
the extreme right is very real it's been
extraordinarily impactful because it has
influenced media coverage of a lot of
these issues media coverage has
influenced public opinion on a lot of
these issues but the Republican party
has moved dramatically to the extreme
and I don't know at this point What's
going to turn it around let me know your
thoughts leave a comment send an email
to info davidpackman.com
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis tried taking the
high road against Donald Trump's recent
attack on him and while I admire
DeSantis I guess in some vague way for
not stooping to Trump's level DeSantis
will lose if this is his approach it
didn't work for any of these Republicans
in 2016 it's not going to work for Ron
DeSantis so let's take a look at this
clip the context here I will remind you
is that Donald Trump published to truth
social Ultra essential a picture of Ron
DeSantis with some allegedly high school
girls
re-trothing a message that argued that
Ron was grooming high school girls
Donald Trump posting that's not Ron is
it he would never do such a thing Ron
DeSantis was asked about this he
attempted to take the high road listen
to this
I spend my time delivering results for
the people of Florida and fighting
against Joe Biden that's how I spend my
time
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I don't spend my time trying to smear
other Republicans
yeah
uh oh how great Ron really really great
you took the high road you will lose if
this is what you do he doesn't have a
chance in hell of defeating Donald Trump
if that is going to be his approach it's
not what Republican voters want to see
at this point he's going with the I'm
above this sort of approach on this
thing and they tried it in 2016. it did
not work it might have gotten you two
three four five six seven percent but
then Trump Consolidated support and
Consolidated and Consolidated DeSantis
does have the possibility of defeating
Donald Trump in a 2024 primary DeSantis
hasn't even announced that he is running
at this point and he's polling really
well against the former president when
he hasn't even said I am actually a
candidate for this office this is not
about DeSantis can't win but think back
to a couple weeks ago a month ago a
month ago two months ago when I told you
pulling aside
I don't know that DeSantis
constitutionally
personality wise has what it takes to go
up against Trump and Trump's nicknames
and Trump's insults in a national
campaign I don't know whether DeSantis
has it in him the fact that he is
already going with I'm above this stuff
I'm not going around criticizing other
Republicans I don't waste my time on
this sort of thing there is not a chance
in hell that DeSantis wins with that
approach if you disagree with me I want
to hear from you I just don't see it and
part of the reason why is that these
Republican voters many of these
Republican voters they don't want unity
and decorum and the right tone or any of
this stuff they voted for Trump they
voted for the guy who said grab them by
the you know what was drawing stuff with
sharpies and said that woman's not
attractive enough for me to ever have
sexually assaulted her they they don't
want Little Marco and Ted Cruz's wife is
ugly and all this different stuff that's
what they wanted that's what they voted
for and while many of them will tell you
a oh I want to return to Civility and
all these things and some of them
genuinely do want that the romney-esque
ones most of them don't most of them
want that Alpha energy that they claim
comes from Donald Trump
uh and they're not going to go for this
so if this is the santis approach he is
dead in the water on this campaign that
hasn't even started yet disagree with me
let me know agree with me I want to hear
from you as well
speaking of Ron DeSantis versus Donald
Trump Fox News and Fox and Friends
specifically
continues to sort of take this approach
of softly and subtly pointing more in
the direction of this of DeSantis than
Donald Trump I'm going to play for you
this is a couple minutes long but it's
worth looking at this in its in its
totality I'm going to play for you a
couple minute segment from this
morning's Fox and Friends in which Steve
Ducey Ainsley Earhart and Brian Kilmeade
I'm reminding myself of their names as I
as I look at them here uh spend a couple
of minutes with sort of erratic word
salads really unclear what the direction
of the segment was it was about polling
it was about these different things but
eventually they get to another subtle
push towards DeSantis and away from
Trump and the one they come up with
today is Biden would rather run against
Trump than DeSantis or put a different
way the way Brian Kilmeade puts it is
Biden is more scared of DeSantis than he
would be of trump and it's another way
to subtly suggest as Fox News has
increasingly been doing subtly they're
not abandoning Trump but they're subtly
pointing to DeSantis DeSantis would be
the stronger candidate because Biden
would rather run against Trump let's
let's really dig into this because
there's a lot here I understand that
people want to dismiss bad polls but his
response yesterday to Judy Woodruff was
yeah 50 people on a cell phone saying
they're unhappy about the direction of
the country we don't really care about
that okay if your polls were good if
they were fine you'd be like the polls
show people improve of the economy was
referring to the fact is that most
people say 50 percent in the Glasgow
poll 50 say they are worse off this year
than last year and 70 percent uh
believed they were heading in the wrong
direction the country said they're
living paycheck to paycheck inflation
gas prices are up and he could Now
understand that two-thirds of the
country living paycheck to paycheck
isn't a new thing four years ago I told
you and remember who was president then
that something like half of Americans
would need to borrow money if they got
hit with an unexpected 400 expense a lot
of this stuff isn't new for a long time
many Americans have felt the countries
going in the wrong direction but there
there you can see that they're sort of
struggling to come up with a story and
eventually the story they shift to is
Biden is more scared of uh DeSantis than
he is of trump they're down they're up
from where they were when he took off
it's just crazy and so the president is
going to Tampa today this is the second
time in two months uh the president or
the vice president have been down in
Florida why is that is it because
DeSantis they're worried about that
could be Senior Communities too uh well
what they're trying to do is uh exactly
and so uh DeSantis Democratic
strategists expect the president to set
the stage for a re-election and draw
contrast with Ron DeSantis you know he's
drawn uh comparisons to Donald Trump in
the past but now it looks and you speak
in the polls you see these polls in Ron
DeSantis is surging it's like okay
forget about Trump for right now let's
let's go ahead and go down to where Ron
DeSantis is and talk about saving all
this stuff Florida was a purple State
and now it's completely red we saw that
19 points uh Rhonda Santos won in a
landslide so it'll be interesting to see
Florida in their minds and bring it back
well I think that he's got a he's got a
message in the area that he feels as
though is experiencing good Economic
Times number one number two seniors he
wants to continue to harp on that uh
inaccurate message that Republicans want
to get rid of in Sunset Medicare and
Social Security and I'll add something
else as good as Ron DeSantis is doing
even though he's getting a pack together
it looks like he's going to run right
Donald Trump's still beating him uh in
most polls and in fact I think he's a
solid second but Trump's still up front
and I just wonder on some level if
President Biden rather have Trump than
than to say well so there it is would
Biden prefer Trump rather than DeSantis
and so this is part of the they have
built uh an ejector seat so to speak so
that if it comes to it that Donald Trump
is not the nominee
they want to get away from Trump as
quickly as possible and they would
rather move Beyond Trump and go to
DeSantis but they can't just bail
altogether because Trump indeed might be
the nominee and if Trump is the nominee
he might indeed be the president again
and Fox News doesn't want to lose access
but this is now like the sixth or
seventh sort of segment that we've seen
from Fox and Friends where they're
either doing the man on the street
interviews where they happen to bump
into all Republicans who want DeSantis
over Trump uh or they're talking about
polling or whatever the case may be they
are continuing the subtle push away from
Trump and towards DeSantis what exactly
their motivation is you know some say
it's because Rupert Murdoch personally
really doesn't like Trump others say
it's because they see the writing on the
wall or it would be better for them for
this that the other thing I don't really
know what the answer is I don't think
it's completely clear and it may be
different for different people at Fox
News but they are setting themselves up
to be right in there with a hypothetical
DeSantis nominee or DeSantis
Administration but they've got to play
it safe and so this is the sort of stuff
that they're doing what do you believe
is fox's motivation and end game let me
know info davidpackman.com or leave a
comment if you're watching on YouTube or
Facebook or Instagram will take a very
quick break and much more coming up
after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
well this really bums me out but
podcaster Joe Rogan on Whose program
I've been a guest twice in the past has
unleashed the Jews Love Money
stereotype Trope call it whatever you
want which is linked to so much ugly
anti-Semitism now I'm gonna play the
clip and I'm going to talk about it I I
do want to say that I don't actually
think that Joe Rogan has a genuinely
anti-semitic bone or anti-semitic
ounce of lean muscle mass in his body
um I think that he just doesn't
understand why saying Jews love money is
different than the example he gives of
Italians love eating pizza I just think
he doesn't get why
uh there are two different things and
it's a very bad analogy and as many of
you know I don't know if Rogan's willing
to have me back on his program you know
I've done some segments since I was last
done which were critical of things he
said but I think I've done them
respectfully and I would be glad to talk
about any of my views about his views
anytime and I would love to explain this
to him as well I have no idea
um but I don't think that this is about
Joe Rogan being an anti-semite
um just based on personally knowing him
let's get into the segment and hear how
it all went down
sitting next to Ilion Omar where she's
she's apologizing for talking about it's
all about the Benjamins yeah which is
just about money she's talking about I
shouldn't have apologized it's not an
anti-semitic statement I don't think
that is it's about Benjamins or money
you know the idea that Jewish people are
not into money is ridiculous listen it's
like saying Italians aren't into Pizza
stupid I understand okay
so listen
um the analogy to Italians eating pizza
couldn't be more misleading and it
couldn't be more wrong and there are a
number of important points here first of
all
analogizing to Republic to Republicans
liking Pizza to Italians liking Pizza
groups Jews liking money under a
category of what we might consider like
positive things and this is the
difficulty with some of these
anti-semitic tropes that in a vacuum
they sound like positive things you know
when people say Jews do so well in the
banking industry you might mean that in
a totally benign way or not but it's
connected to
long-standing conspiracies of Jewish
conspiracy to control certain industries
to their benefit into the detriment of
others and it's wrapped up in really
really ugly stuff so the analogy to it's
just a good thing liking money liking
Pizza it's just it's a it's a totally
fine and good thing that's that's one
issue which is it's connected to
all sorts of historical horrible stuff
that eating pizza by Italian people is
not secondly it's not Jews love money
and Italians love pizza right everyone
loves money Jews are the ones tagged
with the stereotype that they are so
obsessed with money above and beyond
everybody else that they conspire to
acquire it in a way that's different
than everybody else I mean have you met
black people who hate money have you met
white people who say oh money throw it
out put it in the trash burn it of
course not because it's not about liking
money ascribing it to Jews is about
something above and beyond that it's the
conspiracy to obtain money including by
immoral or illegal or deceptive means by
controlling certain industries and it's
different it's Unique in some way and
it's linked to thousands of years of
anti-Semitic Trope stereotypes and
discrimination now Rogan might genuinely
not know that
and so that's why I'm being careful and
saying I'm not alleging Joe Rogan is an
anti-semite in saying these things I
think he just doesn't understand or know
the reasons why this is very different
than Italians like pizza the last thing
about this is the analogy to Pizza is
also a terrible one because Italians
liking Pizza isn't a collective action
linked to anti-italian tropes and
stereotypes about Italian conspiracy to
like pizza or eat pizza like it doesn't
even make sense as I say it doesn't make
any sense you're talking about something
that is individual when the discussion
is about Jews liking money it's no
longer about individuals right it's not
about Jon Stewart likes money he loves
money
it's a trait that is ascribed to the
group working together and that's where
this entire like conspiracy stuff comes
from so uh I you know
it's really important
a lot of times when people say this
stuff they don't actually know or
understand the origins and they go I
don't know it's just like saying Jews
Like Love Money is is like saying black
people are good at basketball is like
saying whatever these sound like
positive things but they're interlaced
inextricably with really ugly historical
things
stereotyping xenophobia all sorts of
stuff and so it is really easy sometimes
for people to defend this sort of thing
and say liking money it's not even a bad
thing but it would be better if people
understood the history and really what
it was that that they were talking about
so again I I have no personal beef with
Rogan and whether or not I've been
blacklisted from his show I genuinely
have no idea but everything I've ever
said on this show about the things Joe
has said I'd be willing to talk about
with him I'm not hiding behind a
microphone or behind the screen or any
of it I don't know if he has any
interest in that but I I am glad to
anytime on his program or on mine I'm
going to play for you
um some number of incoherent seconds I
guess it's about 90 seconds of my pillow
founder and CEO Mike Lindell appearing
on Steve bannon's program and I have to
tell you at this point I genuinely don't
know whether Steve Bannon takes Lindell
seriously because Bannon is as much of
an incoherent joke as Lindell or whether
Bannon sees Lindell more of his like as
a as a goofy entertainment element but
he doesn't take him seriously there was
a segment on Steve bannon's actually I'm
wrong this was on Lindell TV
you know what I don't know where this
seems to have been a simulcast both on
Lindell TV and on on Steve bannon's war
room I don't know where
pillow is upset with Ron DeSantis for
some reason he's calling him a
backstabber and all these different
things the segment starts with Mike
pillow literally holding a pillow and
then moving it out of frame I wasn't
able to find what took place in the 15
seconds before this clip starts but the
presence of the pillow makes me think it
might be pretty damn interesting
see if you can make heads or tails out
of this and then again if you're
listening imagine that as this segment
starts Mike pillow is moving a physical
pillow out of screen so what is going on
does Santa's a pretty straight guy what
is he heckling you because he's upset
about what you're doing in Miami-Dade or
what is a shot across Mike lindell's bow
what's going on here
well let me let me uh let me try and
frame this and this could we'll just say
uh we don't know why but uh you can draw
your own conclusions so this morning
what he hosted a lawyer uh six lawyers
or so in this uh uh in this little round
table well one of them is Libby lock who
represents Dominion voting machines
against it says anything against Mike
Lindell Rudy Giuliani and many others
you guys understanding the so far and he
called her in his opening statement and
when he introduced her Libby is an
extraordinaire at First Amendment
defamation law
well I'm telling you Ron you didn't
watch that you probably won't you
probably don't understand what's going
on in our country there's a reason that
the whole country wanted me to beach out
of the RNC well that obviously isn't the
case when they did the rest for support
it's because I want to get rid of the
machines and and make our elections
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines elections and not
selections so what he did I told the I
told the Daily Beast today Steve they
called me and I said because they
watched it and I said let me tell you
something they called me and they said
sir I said he just blew any chance if he
was thinking of running for president
your ship is sailed run you just will
endorse Donald Trump right now and try
and save peace because you don't know
what the people want now I want to
remind everybody
that
um the D I believe it was the day after
Trump announced in November that he was
running in 2024
I don't remember what the context was
but the day after or two days later Mike
pillow said
DeSantis is about to endorse Trump
DeSantis isn't going to run in 24 any
day now he's going to come out and say
actually I endorsed Donald Trump now of
course that didn't happen like almost
all of Mike pillow's predictions it has
not come true but what is our
understanding of pillow at this point is
he deeply delusional or does he believe
the things he said I don't know the
answer I've interviewed pillow twice
I've most recently been leaning towards
he's serious about this stuff he means
it but now I'm sort of going back like
could anyone really be this delusional
does Steve Bannon take him seriously I
also don't nor know the answer to that I
I don't know what is going on with this
guy we can only hope and pray
that at least within the Republican
party uh which is the only place he has
any credibility left he is increasingly
seen as a joke and ostracized and moved
to the margins of the political
discussion but I knew that day that he
appeared at the White House during covet
with Trump to announce that he believes
Trump was uh god-given a god-given
president
gosh darn it
um you could tell this guy was trouble
and he certainly has turned out to be
trouble and he told me a few months ago
that he's like in for 35 million at that
point he was in for 35 million so far in
all of this election stuff and machines
and investigations and whatever
um it's got to be more than that by now
at some point the money's got to run out
you would think but uh there is the
latest from Mike pillow holding a pillow
uh for part of a segment with Steve
Bannon we have a voicemail number that
number
remains 219 to David P we've been
talking on the world famous bonus show
lately about what's going on with
Netflix accounts oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else it
makes money to find themselves is bad we
make a little bit of money on the bonus
show sure uh the big thing that's
happening with Netflix accounts is a
Crackdown no more sharing accounts
between people who don't live together
and I admitted I'm still on my mommy's
account that's absolutely true it has
all my preferences and my likes and
dislikes and I've been on that account
for I don't know 20 years and I'm gonna
stay on it until they take it away from
me and the Eggman called in to weigh in
on this
hey Dave my daughter turns 21 years old
today happy birthday to her birthday
present for her I told her she can
remain on our Netflix accounts for 30
more years
just like you and your family Shalom
brother yep that's absolutely right I've
got my account on my mom's account my
profile uh my little brother has one as
well
and uh I'm sticking with it until
Netflix takes it away and uh we will see
how long that is we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today
Ultra processed foods what is that
what's the difference between processed
and Ultra processed well we will talk
about it Ultra processed foods may lead
to cognitive decline says a new study is
the study trustworthy we will discuss we
have really good news about Salman
Rushdie
he is back to a certain degree
um we're going to talk about it some
some amazing pictures of Salman Rushdie
published in the New Yorker and we're
going to talk about the aftermath of
that horrible horrible attack that he
was the victim of and lastly the virus
threat is easing from covid but U.S
hospitals are as full as they have ever
been why what is the reason well we're
going to talk about it it's not from
respiratory disease it's from other
things all of those stories and more are
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com you will get instant
access to the show it's really cheap to
sign up
but I understand that many folks would
like a discount and I'm glad to offer
one you can use the coupon code please
no more Trump that's all one word no
spaces please no more Trump you can use
that coupon code to get a discount off
of the cost of a membership and I want
you to remember that we continue the
fight for 2 million YouTube subscribers
you can help us for free by signing up
at youtube.com the davidpackman show and
by the way voting you can only do once
if you have multiple Google accounts you
can subscribe to the YouTube channel
multiple times perfectly legal Carrie
Lakes not coming after you for it
pillows not coming after you for
nobody's coming after you for it so just
just mentioning it just mentioning it we
will see you on the bonus show or
otherwise back tomorrow